les gens se disent bas nous on va
décrocher notre téléphone va vous dire
vous êtes qui on va rester à l'accueil
et puis on va être comme des cons et
puis on va pas trouver de solution on
est d'accord
excusez moi j'ai besoin d'intervenir et
bérénice bérénice 25 ans de nantes
voilà c'est top 1 ce qui se passe sur le
plateau vraiment c'est génial
des privilégiés parce qu'à part sur sa
subaru c'est top
il y en a pas de vent pas en avoir ce
que le gouvernement met en place un jeu
une solution et c'est top aussi moi
personnellement ça ne m'a rien changé à
ma galère si je peux dire bonjour
explique vraiment événements mais
vraiment c'est que c'est top de faire ça
mais c'est beaucoup plus profond que ça
en fait c'est pas juste des mesures sur
mesure qui vont arranger la situation
c'est de la précarité c'est un système
qui ne va pas depuis des années moi déjà
à l'école on m'a toujours dit si j'ai
lampe rouge était une casse hausse
excusez-moi l'état mais c'est ça j'étais
en général on voyait les gens du pro
montée c'était un mince et des cassos
faut que tu faut que tu fasses des
études résultat j'ai fait un bac + 5 je
me suis endetté ce soit pour faire mes
études parce que je vis enfin je dirais
que ma maman qui était tout seul au smic
donc à pouvait pas m'aider
et ce n'est pas une a suscité en ce qu
en ce moment on entend souvent ça que on
assiste trop la france ma mère n'a
jamais été raciste et a travaillé 12
heures par jour à l'hôpital pour être
payés au smic enfin voilà ça me tient
vraiment à coeur en fête c'est que le
système ne va plus depuis trop longtemps
moi je suis pas ici pour me plains non
d'accord puisque je m'en sors moi ça va
je m'en sors comme comme dirait
quelqu'un on traverse la vente rôle du
travail que je trouve du travail tu as
dit ça dans ma branche
mais je veux dire c'est qu'on galère
mais y'a pas que nous montons galère
entre je sais hélas hélas ce soir vous
vous qui êtes sur le plateau vous êtes
des privilégiés parce que c'est vrai que
j'avais compris qu'on allait trouver
d'autres solutions
il ya plein de gens qui disent non moi
je suis chez moi comme a dit bérénice et
moi on va pas me trouver de solution
parce que quand je vais appeler moi une
entreprise comme a dit thibault on va me
raccrocher au nez ou un manière dont on
n'a rien pour vous mais il ya trop de
jeunes qui font des études tous les
métiers manuels l'artisanat la
boulangerie de la climatisation
l'électricité tout ça c'est dévaloriser
ses sous payés donc forcément les jeunes
n'ont pas envie de se lancer là dedans
ce qu'on se lance dans des études sauf
qu'on est comme des cons excusez moi le
terme en écho la région à la sortie
surdiplômés et puis on nous dit vu qu'en
france ça fonctionne comme ça il faut de
l'expérience parce que moi j'ai un bac
tu sens que j'ai fait deux stages donc
c'est faux et encore j'ai eu mon stage
parce que j'ai été pistonné ça aussi
c'est pas bon avoir un stage c'est
impossible sur n'est pas pistonné
malheureusement je suis pas pistonné
pour trouver un job mais il a parlé
récemment grâce à l'association naujac
du talent j'en parlerai plus tard qui
m'a mis en contact
mais ce qu'on veut quand elle veut
changer ça on veut changer ça la
résidence quand je dis qu'on veut
développer l'apprentissage c'est
l'apprentissage éventuellement quand on
est en master 2 c'est aussi et je dirais
même surtout l'apprentissage parce qu'il
ya des tas de boue métiers qui recrutent
des métiers dans lesquels les jeunes
s'éclatent des métiers de boulanger des
métier de forgeron des métiers des
métiers manuels qui sont injustement
dévalorisé est vraiment quand on veut
revaloriser l'apprentissage c'est aussi
pour tous ces métiers où il ya des
énormes besoins dans notre pays si vous
demandez aux boulangers ils ont
absolument besoin de recruter je peux en
train de vous dire vous allez faire
boulanger et je dis que ces bébés et il
existe qu'il faut changer le regard sur
ces métiers
c'est pour ça qu'on développe
l'apprentissage mais on a battu tous les
records sur le nombre de contrats
d'apprentissage en 2020 et on veut
continuer en 2021 pour inciter les
entreprises
on est des aides pour qu'ils disaient
voilà je dirais presque pas d' excuses
pour pas embaucher un apprenti donc on
veut effectivement changer ça et puisque
10 bérénice est aussi important c'est
que oui c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui même
quand on a son diplôme à c'est ça bien
souvent si on n'a pas le réseau eh ben
on n'y arrive pas je même quand elles
vous avez c'est sous payés a fait des
études chez un master 2 ils ont été
proposés simic
alors que tu a galéré cinq ans tu dis
bah on doit aller à l'école où on doit
ce soit alors que vous faites la
promotion de l'école justement camier
les deux cas les diplômés d'un master 2
en industrie culturelle la cherche son
premier emploi depuis neuf mois
camille après et camille on va écouter
votre cas le problème qu'on a madame la
ministre
c'est qu'aujourd'hui comme l'a libéré
nice où on a toujours entendu tu fais
des études et tu trouveras un travail et
tu seras content et aujourd'hui le
problème c'est que les gens me disent je
vais faire des études et je me
retrouvais comme un conte à chercher un
emploi elle a fait un master 2 voilà on
l'a vu bérénice 80 stage parce qu'elle a
eu elle a été questionnée comme aldi
elle connaissait quelqu'un mais pour un
emploi elle est pas pistonné et c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui c'est compliqué
aussi de dire aux jeunes il faut que tu
travailles à l'école il faut que tu
passes des études si derrière y'a rien
c'est ça bien compliqué d'abord moi je
pense qu'il faut arrêter de dire aux
jeunes que les métiers manuels
pas bien et que c'est pour ça qu'on
développe l'apprentissage pour qu'ils
aillent aussi vers ces métiers
je pense que ce qui est important aussi
de se dire c'est que on se forme au
début de sa vie et on pourra se
continuer à se former tout au long de sa
vie donc on n'est pas forcément obligé
de continuer des études très longues
peut aussi faire un ca paix ou avoir un
stack peau et continuer après à se
former c'est la formation continue qu'on
pousse beaucoup savez on a mis des
moyens comme on en a jamais mis pour que
chacun sache qui peut démarrer dans la
vie professionnelle
et puis qu'au cours de sa vie pourra
aussi être accompagné pour se former
pour trouver un nouveau métier donc je
pense que c'est aussi important et c'est
aussi cambéréne il dit qu'on peut pas
trouver ça qu'on avait un monsieur quand
on n'a pas le 06 on n'y arrive pas c'est
vraiment pour ça
le président de la république a voulu
qu'on passe de 20000 mentor à 100000
mentor c'est justement des personnages
importants le mentorat dont on passé est
essentielle
je pense que c'est essentiel qu'on ait
des gens qui nous tendent la main qui
sont chefs d'entreprise qui sonde assure
cabinet d'avocats et qui vont vous aider
à rentrer dans le monde du travail ce
que je vais vous dire aujourd'hui
bérénice
elle a parlé concrètement à la raison
c'est vrai que quand on connaît pas moi
je me rappelle moi je prends mon exemple
moi mon père quand je lui dis je veux
faire de la télé il m'a dit moi je
connais personne
donc tu feras jamais de télé comment tu
veux que je te trouve un stage comment
tu veux je te trouve un truc il ya plein
de jeunes qui sont dans ce cas l'avs